okay today I'm going to talk to you
about kinetic energy whenever we talk
about kinetic energy the first thing we
always think of is movement because
essentially what kinetic energy is is
how much energy moving object has how
much energy is stored within a moving
object so there's two different things
that can kind of influence the amount of
kinetic energy an object has so let's
imagine we've got two people here this
person here they are walking briskly at
five meters per second was this person
here this is Usain Bolt and he's running
at ten meters per second so which one of
them of the two has more kinetic energy
well obviously the one with the greater
velocity so velocity is one thing that
can affect kinetic energy so what's the
other thing let's imagine this time
we've got the same person again this
person here who is traveling at five
meters per second but this time we have
a lorry that it's also traveling at five
meters per second so they're traveling
at the same velocity which one has more
kinetic energy or the lorry does because
mass also contributes towards kinetic
energy the greater the mass the greater
the kinetic energy so with that in mind
that helps us to figure out and
understand this equation the equation
for kinetic energy I'm just using ke
here for kinetic energy is half times
mass times velocity squared that is the
equation that we have to remember
because remember velocity and mass both
influence the size of kinetic energy so
let's have a quick look at a typical
kind of exam question calculate the
kinetic energy of a hundred kilogram man
who is walking at velocity of five
meters per second so let's first of all
go through and annotate it it's 100
kilograms that's my value for mass five
meters per second that is my value for
velocity so again let's remind ourselves
of the equation we're going to use
kinetic energy equals oh sorry obviously
we need to label that as kinetic energy
as well kinetic energy equals 1/2 times
mass times velocity squared okay so um
what I need to do next is I just need to
put this into my calculator say it's 1/2
remember 1/2 you could use a 0.5 times
mass times velocity squared so my
kinetic energy equals 1250 but let's see
kinetic energy whenever we've got energy
I know that it's measured in joules so
that's quite simply how to carry out a
kinetic energy calculation so remember
the equation we need to remember is 1/2
times mass times velocity squared
because increasing the mass increases
the kinetic energy and increasing the
velocity increases the genetic energy
and this is how we apply it to an exam
question thank you